this question in two parts I guess many
for Lily Kenneth and Sandy there have
been concerns raised so more than once
about the corseting in Cinderella's
dress and how thought eensy-teensy it
makes her waist the animated version has
obviously been a sort of a family
favorite for decades but parents have
raised concerns about issues of body
image and the impression that the dress
could leave on their children the word
about taking their children to see it I
guess the first part is do you think
those concerns are fair and the second
part is do they concern you at all so
indeed you want to pick that I'll go
first um I don't I don't understand what
the concerns are actually I mean the
Lily does have a small waist but then so
do all the other girls in the film all
the girls in the film are wearing
corsets because that's what you wear
with period clothes so it creates that
the silhouette for the period holiday
and Kate everyone else had small waist
too Lily's dress in particular is an
optical illusion I have to say I mean
the diameter of the skirt is about two
meters and then it's got the width here
and that really does make the waist look
smaller than it actually is I mean can I
just say one thing I'm a mom and the
produced one of the producers of the
film and I think it's um it's gotten a
lot of attention but the funny thing is
he's kind of paying attention to the
opposite of the theme of the movie which
is your sense of beauty and your
strength
is what's on the inside and and Sandy's
right I was there for all of the early
fittings I would look like I have a two
inch waist there's a giant set of
shoulders and there's butterflies and it
was customary for women to be coarse at
the time and there's - is it two miles
of fabric in the skirt so not only is an
optical illusion but I think it's so
interesting that the conversation has
been about the outside because this is a
movie where the real emphasis is on the
inside so as a mom I would really
encourage us to really because my 12
year old daughter thought the dress was
really pretty but what she took away
from the film was the priority of
courage and kindness
yeah like the questions that you have
from your daughter and I've had friends
kids and little boy Daniel he's nine and
he said it's amazing how you promised
your mom to be kind and good when you
remembered it and I just thought that's
the message why on earth are we focusing
on something so irrelevant you know so
much wonder the next question shall we
at lady in the front here please and we
got your microphone they already know
let's get one two this lady here quickly
thank you that'd be great thanks hi
auntie Lily and kind of first of all
congratulations on the film and
Cinderella is an iconic character loved
by generations touching on what you've
just sort of said in an era where Disney
are trying to reinvent the Disney
princess as it were how do you feel
Cinderella is stepping up to this modern
audience and what's it say to young
girls today go for well I think it's
sort of what we're talking about this
strength can come from within this
dignified strength and grace and and
also that in doing so she finds such joy
and happiness in her life regardless of
her situation even if it's just talking
to little gus-gus but when I read the
script I was sort of bowled over by the
fact that it was such a truthful you
know retelling of the fairy tale without
any tricks or twists really but it felt
really strong and a girl I really wanted
to play and felt inspired playing her it
feels as though it's a different it's a
different kind of empowerment but I
think it is empowerment and I think that
she makes proactive choices even even if
those choices are sometimes to be
thoughtful and to be considerate so so
it's a question maybe of reconsidering
the notion of action and empowerment I'm
going to quote this would be weird at a
press conference but I'm going to
probably about to quote Gandhi right so
he says these these are quotes that were
at the the memorial service for the
great Richard Attenborough the other day
some lines from Gandhi - to apply and we
discussed this this function seems like
a crazy thing to talk about in relation
to Cinderella but I think it goes to the
heart of the question Gandhi said
amongst many other things when I despair
I remember that all through history the
way of truth and love have always won
there have been tyrants and murderers
and for a time they can seem invincible
but in the end they always fall think of
it always and in relation to why someone
like perhaps Cinderella doesn't do some
of the things that some people may
expected to do but does them in a
different way he may have some light to
throw on it in this way when he says
there are many causes I would die for
not one I would kill for an eye for an
eye only turns the whole world blind and
so we tried to find in an obviously a
much lighter way that attempts to you
know trip lightly over it the sort of
the soul of the piece in in there but
the truth is something like Cinderella
has the possibility of encompassing that
amount of detail which we don't ever
need to spell out to a five-year-old
child it's just in the fabric of that
it's in the fabric of the doing of it
and so when people talk about the
sincerity of the movie it comes from
that that sort of that sort of place not
because we're trying to be
holier-than-thou it's just that I
believe it
you